[موسيقى]
علاقتنا بالمناخ علاقه تعايش فنحن لا ناكل
ولا نشرب ولا نلبس ولا نسكن الا على
مجرياته وفي الصباح ننتشي وفي الظهر ننكمش
ونكون كله خلق بتناغم وبنسب موزونه ان كل
شيء خلقناه بقدر والانسان منذ القدم حافظ
على عناصر قواعده من الاخلال ليش لانه هو
مصدر حياته حافظ على الماء وعلى النبات
وعلى الحياه الفطريه وهذه هي الثالوث
المعيشي لحياته انا مثل الماء سهل سائق
ومتى احمي هذا وقتل غير اني في زمان من
يكن فيه اذا مال هو المولى
الاجل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فالانسان منذ القدم حافظ على المياه
والنبات والحياه الفطريه وجعل لها حرمه
فلا تنتهك فبنى السدود وجعل الحمى
للمحافظه عليها والسد هو الحاجز او الحابس
لمياه الشعاب والانهار والاوديه والماء هو
الحياه وجعلنا من الماء كل شيء حي افلا
يؤمنون
[موسيقى]